it changed my life and so when i think
about um how do we or how do i help
people not get there in the first place
and what are the things because
everything became in hindsight
um one of the things actually in just
the healing process is i going back to
ownership i was waiting for a doctor to
fix me so when it happened first of all
i was like okay what's the right pill i
have to take and hey doctor what's wrong
right and you literally go to the doctor
and you're like okay this is this doctor
came recommended and this person has a
special degree and they've got famous
people on their wall you convince
yourself that an expert quote-unquote is
going to help fix
you
and every time i went there i had hope
and every time i left i had zero hope
yeah and but it was the hope i was
chasing really in hindsight right so i
think i just kept going to the doctor
being like okay well this one's gonna
this one's gonna fix me and eventually
what i ended up realizing was i was
actually giving my power away
so by looking outside of myself by
looking to a doctor to say hey can you
um fix me i was giving it away now i
didn't come to that conclusion though
until i realized i'd actually all the
things that went wrong with my own
health were due to me so once i started
to process and i looked back why did i
get so sick
i was like you know what i took a lot of
antibiotics like a lot it got to the
point where i was on antibiotics like
four times a year five times a year
because i was getting so sick all the
time so originally
i was blaming the doctors well he
shouldn't give me that many antibiotics
and after a while after two years of
literally just searching for someone to
help and save me once i realized i saved
myself i literally was like hang on a
minute i keep saying
they gave me antibiotics but i swallowed
them
every time a doctor said yeah
right it's like every time a doctor kept
saying you know i probably shouldn't
give you this many antibiotics not once
did i say why not and not once did i go
home and google what does to take in too
many antibiotics lead to
and so once i started to realize
that by telling saying that it was
therefore i was now giving the power
away once i switched it
and said
this is all my fault and if it was my
fault now i can fix it and fit what does
fixing look like i stopped turning to
doctors i acknowledged
that i had
done it to myself that i was ignoring
the flags you even said right we push
under the rug
i now had to stop and pause and say what
was i actually pushing under the rug
what did that look like okay when i had
this pain i did this okay did that serve
me right like when i was you know on the
floor holding my gut i sucked it up and
went to another four hours of a photo
shoot all right well did that serve me
yes or no no that didn't serve me okay
so next time lisa
next time you fall on the floor
you're going to say
i'm taking the rest of the day off right
like coming up with rules that when this
happens because you've already been
there and you have control and you're
the one that is going to heal yourself
because it's all your fault you have to
come up with a game plan
and so with no judgment i res
that we played all the red flags that
happened i started to say when this flag
happens i'm going to do this when i wake
up tired i'm going to do this when i get
a stomach crack cramp i'm going to do
this and i took ownership and that meant
i got an oaring because i was waking up
tired all the time and i'm like i'm
sleeping like nine now
why am i tired all the time
so i wore an orange i wore a continuous
glucose monitor
and i started to assess i started to
write down i'd go to bed at nine o'clock
in the evening i would wake up according
to my aura ring at 2 a.m
and according to my glucose monitor i
would have actually crashed at around
150. oh hypoglycemia oh
is there a correlation between my blood
sugars and how much i sleep
how was i feeling the next day i felt
exhausted all right what time did i eat
dinner well you ate dinner at 8pm okay i
went to bed at 9. what if i ate two
hours in between what if i ate three
hours in between what if i went keto
like i literally
tried everything and i wrote everything
down and then
i went and said
you know when you say trust your gut
it's like how many of us ignore our gut
oh
all of us many times i mean most of the
time
yes i mean but
ask anyone how many times your gut was
wrong and they'll be like
um that's never been wrong yeah right
because the problem is that we don't
want to hear it when it's bad we don't
want to hear it when it's like don't do
that we don't want to hear it when it's
like
you should probably get out of that
relationship you know we don't want to
hear it when you shouldn't be treated
like that we don't want to hear it when
you better try that we we just want to
hear the oh look there's a butterfly
oh you're doing great this is a 11-11
sign yeah
we don't want we we don't want to hear
the bad stuff but
it's because you have to face it right
and look facing it sometimes really
freaking sucks
like facing the hard truth that's why i
wrote the chapter like open up the can
of worms and embrace the ick it's like
sometimes open up the can of worms only
leads to horrible worms and you're like
i don't want to deal with worms so let
me just not open it right like and i
equate it to the hard questions what am
i happy do i actually want to be in this
relationship because to your point what
if the answer is no
and now if you're married what if you've
got kids and your answer is actually i'm
not happy in this relationship now you
have to say well do i have to go to
therapy do i you know i have to tell
them do they want to go to therapy what
if we go to therapy and it doesn't work
what if what if you
find out that they've cheated on me can
i forgive them does that mean we have to
get a divorce i mean we have to sell the
house who gets the kids what happens at
christmas right like
whatever
yes
right what if i can't find anyone after
that because now they've actually seen
the truth right there's so many things
that come with it
that i get why it ends up well we don't
want to even ask the freaking question
in the first place because it becomes
easier now i don't know about you but
not once i've had so many therapists on
my show
not one relationship therapist has ever
said
that someone comes in and is like i
didn't even realize this was over until
today most of the time
they come in like i knew this marriage
was over five years ago
yeah
how often but we we try and it's like
it's actually a beautiful thing about us
as humans we try to make something work
and it's like but only if it's the same
with the health it's like oh well this
will be fine in a week no you'll be fine
to actually ask myself what would life
look like lisa if you had gut issues for
the rest of your life is too much of a
big audacious question to ask i can't
even comprehend what my life would look
like now remember i said at the
beginning girl i started this i'm six
years in i thought it was going to be a
week
oh god i hear i mean i hear you my like
stuff started with oh it's your thyroid
and i'm like oh great i'll just take
this pill and everything will be perfect
and that was a year ago and that's like
trivial compared to you know the point
that i'm at now and so what happened
then when you
start writing everything down you're
tracking everything
you talked about opening up that can of
worms like yeah did you have to face
something that you didn't want to face
so i had ready to yet um it wasn't that
i wasn't ready to but it was the it was
what i kind of known all along so i was
like i hadn't had a period in so many
years and so i was like guys this
doesn't quite match like i was going i'm
like doesn't my hormones got anything to
do with in my garden like no of course
it doesn't it's that's your like but now
this was six years ago we've learned so
much since then as well yeah you can
imagine like
because if
it seems weird i haven't had a period
like surely and but doctors no no no so
i went in after eventually i'd owned
okay lisa if this was all your fault
what do you have to do i went in and got
my own blood work done i went in and got
my own hormones checked i went into a um
gastroenterologist and um
not gastroenteritis a gynecologist sorry
and
when they like huh this is one of the
most horrifying stories so i go in there
i haven't had my period in years i go
i'm thinking okay you know it's um
i'm sure it's got to do with my health
i'm underweight like if they're going to
tell me like all this diet blah
blah
and
blah
she comes in with a little clipboard and
she goes oh
it looks like actually you've got pcrs
like polycystic ovary syndrome
and i'm like oh my god do i she was yeah
oh it looks it says here that you don't
want children i was like no i think she
because i think you're fine i'm like
excuse me she says well if you don't
want children you're fine i'm like i'm
sorry because i don't want kids it's
okay to leave cysts on my ovaries
it was so horrifying and at the same
time so enlightening to how people think
yeah all right
and instead of getting angry at that
point i was like yeah that's about right
that's
that's how other people think and
instead of getting annoyed at them go
lisa this is your life you're taking
ownership over it don't settle for that
doctor going you then you're fine don't
settle for what they were gonna do
because that's what she would do that's
why she's telling you that it's
something like i had a specialist on a
hormone specialist and something like it
takes eight diagnosis for women's
hormones for them to actually be
accurate it's something crazy like that
oh my god
like it's something like on the eighth
doctor they actually get it somewhat
accurate on women's hormones it that's
i mean i i
i went in for the that the reason why i
went in the doctor last year was for the
same reason i had plenty of other red
flags and symptoms and signs but it was
losing my cycle and i was like all right
this is probably bad you you get those
indicators along the way that we're like
shoot this isn't right and it's a matter
of dealing with them so
what i mean
in the end what what what was that what
was the big lesson in it
the lesson was that it's an evolution
and um
every step was a focus of how do i get
progressively better versus how do i get
completely well
and even when i think about business and
i think about everything i do that
really is the goal like what what am i
trying to build what is that skill set
that i can incrementally get better
every day to your point earlier about
you being your own competition right
it's like okay what what number how fast
was i yesterday and how fast can i get
be today um as well as having that big
audacious dream of like i'm gonna get
the world cup or whatever the cup is um
you know and so that's kind of i have
the big audacious dream of one day lisa
you will be perfect but today instead of
being like putting so much weight and
pressure over oh my god i can't believe
i'm not there yet
it's like what's that thing i'm going to
do today so it was things like it takes
three hours for your body to completely
digest your food so
for an entire year you think i'm joking
but to the minute for the entire year i
didn't go to bed once
with three less than three hours from
eating and going to bed so if tom and i
oh infinitely
overnight girl when i'm telling you take
your last from your last swallow so it
would be from the last swallow i would
take ownership i would look at the time
and go oh crap it's 7 p.m i now have to
stay up till 10 p.m now look i'm very
strict on myself i go to bed at 9pm
so if my food got off i would still
stick to the fact that i cannot go to
bed with a full stomach i must go to bed
with an empty stomach so it was go to
bed with an empty stomach for three
hours then start trying foods i don't
care what the doctors say i don't care
what studies say i don't care what all
the specialists say
start eating food and take a journal of
how you feel lisa and what i realized
was that raw food was wrecking my guts
if i ate
fatty beef i felt like i was on cloud
nine
[Music]